[Music]
come piety Antony yes that's me Anthony
how are you come on eat what are you
doing
Oh getting old sucks don't ever let
anybody tell you any different oh this
is a Martha and Bethany this is
Spencer's grandfather's ready Martha
you're the little girlfriend mornin
morning sir I'm sorry to barge in on you
you're not barging he's barging my
little Walker wait my love like like
Milo and Eddie's pleased to meet you man
my dad said you guys had the best
restaurant in town we were just there
well it's called North now Nora's it's
barely even a restaurant it's more like
a breakfast place now we would Spencer
no we came here looking for him actually
y'all hungry things on the griddle I
have to take a look at that hey man you
can do more than take a look at what
look like I need a hand Martha
hey where is he you know something it's
probably the heater it's broken how did
it even get here maybe he maybe he went
backwards is he trying to fix it why
would anyone try to fix that thing I
don't know I don't know and maybe he
went to buy parts or something
okay look I'm calling him again I'm sure
everything's fine
14 texts and four missed calls I don't
think you went out I think I think you
went back in guys guys how is he gonna
get out he's gonna take the green jewel
and stick it back in the statue thing by
himself
we gotta go get him are you crazy I'm
coming with you are you out of your
minds we can do this we've been there we
know what to expect
I got a stopping in her white people I
don't know what the hell is wrong with
me
she's right we've played before and we
won we barely survived you know he would
do it for you for any of us
be careful looks pretty busted give me
the big dark guys here
okay here we go boy is this part
you guys
[Music]
am I
Spencer what in tarnation mm what the
hell is this Eddie what the hell are you
my love Walker who are you Milo what on
earth wait a minute
oh no this isn't happening pardon me who
are you
you're Spencer's grandfather yeah no
kidding and you or Milo
I certainly am I'm Martha Spencer's you
ought a little girlfriend
[Music]
yes I'm fridge damn it the hell man okay
okay so something went wrong you think
holy wait if I'm then you Spencer why
does everybody keep calling me Spencer
no that is grandpa Eddie and dad is Milo
pleased to meet you
what then where's Bethany and we're
Spencer I don't know okay the game it
didn't let us pick our avatars so
because it's busted yeah okay are we
dead you know I was just wondering the
same thing
did I die and turn into some kind of a
small muscular boy scout we're not dead
so then what's going on here okay
this is gonna sound very strange but we
are in a video game called Jumanji and
we are in the bodies of video game
characters
we've been here before fridge and I but
last time I was you hmm huh
we're in a gate we got to find Spencer
because he's in here too
Spencer yes he's here
yes Spencer Eddy's grandson yes Spencer
he said - yes he's here and we gotta
find him so it's like a ha didn't go
seek situation I'm not yet
[Music]
my hip feels pretty good now all my
joints if you like but uh oh yeah look
at those goodies what I got we have some
issues here you telling me this
I'm the old fat dude I came back and
things actually got worse at least last
time I was still black well look at this
little fella
hello there well that there was a
hippopotamus mm-hmm and they are awfully
fast faster than a horse if you can
believe that and they've got an awful
ferocious bite how about that you know
the funny thing is I don't remember
knowing much about hippos until right
now
you're a zoologist I'm sorry I wouldn't
have are we in Florida
just listen this is a dangerous place
crazy dangerous but Martha and I we've
been here before we know what we're
doing
you gotta stay alert all the time if I'm
near water I got one eye on the water
you hear me you got to have eyes in the
back
Oh God
what in the Sam Hill just happened to
happen shut the front door right right
here right here do you know where you
are where are we
we're back in the jungle baby we went
into this knowing that we've got to
raise the bar we got a level up
[Music]
the great parts of making these movies
is that we all genuinely really have a
good time I was excited to get the gang
back together oh my god you guys hi
[Music]
all I remember doing during this shoot
is cry laughing I don't know how they've
gotten any take so it's the funniest
that I've ever seen
on disk and digital
[Music]
you